[upbeat music]
I'm trying to make...
Well, I'm starting
with a bicycle helmet
and I got these colored
popsicle sticks,
hopefully it will be like two
Valkyrie wings.
I have some spackle that I
dyed with paint,
and it's supposed to look like
cake frosting.
I really like the color.
It's very pink and vibrant,
so I'm happy with that.
I've had a stuffed animal
penguin since I was a baby, and
he's kind of gone with me
through life, including college.
And he's been there
when times have been tough.
I guess what I'll miss
most are the people I've met
along the way here at Yale.
Definitely wonderful people.
A lot of wonderful people
that I met.
Gonna miss being part of such
like a vibrant community here.
♪